step by step Israel says it's advancing
in Gaza newly released video showing
what the Israeli military calls an
expansion in its ground operations prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu says it's
necessary to get rid of hamas's military
capabilities and ensure the release of
more than 200 captives both civilian and
Military being held in the Gaza
Strip the ground operation that we
extended can help us bring the hostages
back that's what we promise now
bring them home a promise that hasn't
reassured relatives of those held
captive or missing they're feeling angry
and anxious that their loved ones are at
risk of being killed by Israel's air
strikes so we were very clear about that
all the hostages will come back home
with any kind of negotiation that done
or will be done that we want all back
and we don't care what they will give
for that during a meeting with the
families he said the escalation of
bombardment through air Land and Sea
will force Hamas to hand over those it's
holding if I were to say what the key is
the key is pressure the greater the
pressure the greater the
chances Hamas says it's willing to
release all captives
immediately we have a large number of
enemy captives and the price of turning
them is the emptying of all prisons and
releasing all
prisoners 6,600 Palestinian prisoners
are being held in Israeli jails many
including children have been held for
years without charge or trial under
so-called administrative detention
rules now Qatar the US and Egypt are
continuing to mediate the release of all
captives many Israelis including
captives families say the only option is
to release Palestinian prisoners Sarat
Al jazer occupied East Jerusalem David
Des Ros is a professor of at the
National Defense University and formerly
the pentagon's director of Arabian
Peninsular Affairs he says Israel is not
prepared for a ground
Invasion hostages are really really hard
because it's a constraint on your
freedom of action and at the same time
uh usually the family members of
hostages uh start to make their own
demands and they're demands uh restrict
your policy actions I think in general
Netanyahu is defaulting to his um his
normal mode which is uh security
pressure uh the Hardline approach uh but
I think it is probable that the presence
of the hostages has restrained him from
acting as he otherwise might there's
three problems really in in Netanyahu
going ahead with a full-fledged ground
Invasion right now or two days ago the
first is that the hostages probably
would be um killed in this either by
their captors or as part of the uh you
know the civilian damage that goes on
the second uh problem is the immense
strategic damage Israel's taking around
the world because you know when they
conduct military operations in builtup
areas you kill a a large number of
civilians as your reporting has shown
and then the third problem is I just
don't think the Israeli military is
really prepared for this yet I think
they have to build up their numbers
their combat forces and get their forces
because fighting in a city is just very
difficult consumes a lot of Manpower and
a lot of resources takes a while to have
that prepared and ready to go an
invasion is a political problem but you
can invade and withdraw if you occupy
Gaza you become responsible for the uh
quality of life of everybody who lives
there and uh you know you you add uh two
million uh Palestinians to the overall
Israeli population that that undermines
the very nature of the Israeli state so
it's a political dilemma that follows
after a military dilemma but the problem
is for Netanyahu he has to stay in power
or else he's in a little bit of trouble
personally